une production du studio sf bio sans
filtre le podcast on parle de ce qu'on
veut que nos invités date ph quentin pas
avec moi spécialement aujourd'hui d'une
plante pour plein de raisons notamment
le fait qu on sait planifier un peu
dernière minute qu'on s'est rendu compte
qu'on avait pas d'introduction
enregistré pour le podcast de cette
semaine donc voici pardonnez moi j'avais
un mariage hier ma voix est un petit peu
brisé une petite annonce rapidement
avant de commencer le podcast on a lancé
un deuxième podcast de mémoire qui
s'appelle sans filtre vip qui est
exclusif à nos membres et oui on le sent
fête vip en fait c'est le même principe
que le sans filtre on soit simplement
des gens moins connus donc des gens de
notre entourage qui ont tout aussi tout
autant quelque chose à dire que les gens
qu'on soit sur le 100 fait le podcast
mixons sont moins connus par le public
général
donc le principe est le même on s'assoit
on jase de tout et de rien puis
s'ensuivent des conversations
extrêmement intéressante
on a sorti notre deuxième épisode avec
louis philippe fournier qui se trouve
être mon agent ainsi que l'agent de
plusieurs influences au web c'est aussi
un ancien joueur de hockey il joue
encore au cumin ans y est il que les
connais beaucoup aller les joueurs de la
ligue nationale puisque ces choses dont
on a parlé de tirs entre autres supports
conversation super conversation c'est
vraiment super je me sens attristé par
le fait que je vais faire ça vite aller
sur pékin dans d'espions la vidéo le
lien le clic est là dessus abonnez vous
ces autres contenus exclusifs ses
couettes mène cette semaine au sans fil
podcast dans toute cette dame qui fait
ça je vais essayer de le faire pardonner
- on a reçu jean martin aussant un homme
politique extrêmement parts important
pour le mouvement souverainiste au
québec
c'est un économiste de formation qui a
étudié et travaillé un peu partout dans
le monde c'est un homme pianiste un
érudit de musique c'est un homme
extrêmement
un communicateur hors pair c'est
vraiment c'était vraiment une
conversation extrêmement enrichissante
jean martin qui en ce moment travail à
la guilde qui est une 1re groupement de
concepteur de jeux vidéo indépendants
nous parler de tout ça aussi on a parlé
de parler d'occupation double
étrangement jean martin et ans et qui a
écouté saison d'occupation double avait
calé la bullshit dennebroeucq c'est
vraiment pas grave c'est vraiment ce que
je commence à on dirait que j'ai on
dirait qu'ils jugent les autres et que
j'ai fait le temps d'un jeu back adamo
qui est un podcast sur le studio sf que
vous pouvez écouter à tous les mercredis
ça sort adamo qui reçoit des gens du hip
hop mais on a aussi dit j'ai du temps
discutent sur le sans fil de potins et
sur le studio sf pardon j'ai du temps
qui reçoit des gens de toutes les
milieux et qu'il ya des conversations
autour de leur vie et on va avoir
d'autres podcast sur le studio cf donc
rester à l'affût en attendant
abonnez-vous commenté sur le podcast
jean martin aussant
je m'excuse d'avancé pour ce que vous
venez d'endurer la prochaine fois je
vous jure d'être là et moi ce serait pas
juste moi qui qui parle un petit peu
comme ce n'importe comment donc sans
plus attendre
bompas thiès
[Musique]
bonjour je compte continuer la course a
fait fait que tu t'es fait emporter par
rodez oui sa première année que l'écouté
puis j'ai trouvé ça intéressant
à quel niveau ben je me laisser prendre
dans l'intrigué de savoir ce qui se
passerait la semaine d'après et qu'ils
gagneraient je faisais mib est aussi
mais c'est un pas d'un point de vue
sociologique d'analyser le comportement
humain comme certaines personnes font
c'était vraiment pas par pur
divertissement divertissement j'aimais
bien aussi les petites intrigues mais
c'est toujours un peu ça c'est logique
par ace et les personnalités déjà
ressortir puis les psychologies en fait
c'est surtout le permettent a insulté
moi j'ai étudiant en économie en théorie
des jeux et beaucoup de théorie des jeux
là dedans qu'est-ce que je devrais dire
pour que l'autre jusqu'à la théorie des
jeux concrètement ce qu'est ce que je
suis c'est l'étude des comportements
stratégiques et théorie des jeux et
collaborative et non collaborative donc
ça s'applique à l'économie parce que les
industries dans une industrie une
compagnie veut avoir la part de marché
de l'autre on veut faire des publicités
ou tel move économique
ça s'applique un amour quand on sort si
wingman ça peut aider les petites
stratégies comme ça si tout le monde va
pour la blonde personnes guette l'aide
mais si on va pour les quatre amies de
la blonde qu'on laisse la blonde seul le
tout le monde guette l'oeil du chauffe
la blanc tu me regardes ça s'est un peu
inspiré de la vie de john nash qui est
ouverte et l'équipe du rac le dilemme du
prisonnier toutes ces choses c'est des
mathématiques quand on modélise c'est
très mathématique mais c'est dans la vie
de tous les jours ça s'applique ultimate
imaginant un barça a une longueur
d'avancé caisse compris si parfois trop
mathématiques
[Rires]
c'est le temps des allergies surprises
d'émotions car on parle d'un achat
les équations de jardinage c est ce qu
est ce que ces femmes là était parce que
moi c'est un de mes films favoris j'ai
adoré ce film là sur plein plein de
niveaux est ce que ce ne l'était pour
quelqu'un qui connaît bien ce milieu
leur est ce que c'est un film qui est
représentatif de la réalité aussi
vraiment trop tirée par les cheveux
ben c'est hollywood disait un peu
surtout à la fin de la façon qu'ils
dépensaient schizophrénie je sais pas si
c'est un peu comme ça mais c'est le lot
c'est un génie puis ce qui est à portée
on le voit un petit peu dans le film
parce que tout le reste a fait de même
dans la structure de société aujourd'hui
par exemple quand ils émettent des
nouvelles licences pour des radios ou
des ondes 3g 4g et 5g
il utilise le système d'enchères qui
sont basés sur la théorie des jeux
car des gars comme j'aime nash tournage
donc ce qui a fait de l'application
pratique ça se voit pas au premier degré
parce qu'il est juste des équations tout
le long des grandes économies qui font
des choses trop compliquées cinq dix
quinze ans après ça s'applique dans
sociétés de lait quand même des
débouchés boucle c'est intéressant être
capable d'avoir le recul la capacité
analytique de remarquer ces choses-là
voir à quel point la théorie peut
s'appliquer dans la pratique la société
devrait dans n'importe quelle discipline
moche économistes mais je souhaitais
sociologue sans aucun you dont mêmes les
kinésiologues où les physios il voit
quelqu'un marché savoir que je change de
sa posture de ce qu'internet domaines de
formation on voit tout ce qui découle de
sa part suite des récents de voir que
c'est pas nécessairement tout le temps
que c'est pas à l'avant-plan tout le
temps parfois des solutions qui peuvent
apparaître comme simple quand la
connaissance ne sont pas appliquées
c'est justement maintenant qu'on garde
la messe et s'appuient pvc souvent la
dent dans tousles toutes les questions
sociales ou de séries mettons que on n'a
pas souvent parce que parce que ça me
préoccupe beaucoup le véganisme par
exemple parce que j'ai j'ai acquises des
connaissances depuis que je m'y
intéresse j'ai appris j'ai eu des
connaissances depuis que je m'intéresse
chi chi chi
m'apparaissent comme clarté parce que de
cette reconnaissance le piquant quand tu
vois dans la société c'est que ces
théories là aussi connaissance le sont
justes inconnus ou ignorés c'est
fascinant voir à quel point la
connaissance n'est pas partagée d'un
point de vue société huawei moi
j'aimerais beaucoup et j'étais mégane
végétarien je l'étais pendant un an qu
en espagne parce que j'ai vu une espèce
de gigot de bienne s'est produit dans un
camion qui avait débouclé s'arrêter non
moi ici vrai je m'étais priver de viande
par un petit bout mais je m'enrichis
tout le temps faut vraiment que je fasse
des efforts je pense que ça fait partie
de la solution d'être végétarien ou de
manger moins de viande ou moi
certainement d'un point de vue
économique on entend souvent en fait moi
j'entends souvent l'argument quand le
contre argument a fait du droit mais
tout les emplois qu'ils sont chrétiens à
partir de l'industrie de la viande des
emplois disparaître est qu'est-ce qu'on
qu'est-ce qu'on en fait d'un point de
vue que ça s'appelle l'évolution des
sociétés chant richard tu y étais contre
l'évasion de l'automobile puis les
producteurs de chevaux aussi dépositaire
de chandelles levée de fonds chez kana
paul été éventé même aux données
s'appelle peut-être le progrès puis je
pense que la quantité de céréales et de
ressources et d'eau que ça prend pour
élever du bétail pour nourrir les
humains alors que la matière première
pourrait nourrir les humains avec moins
de ressources
on va peut-être y arriver une c4 il faut
en tout cas pas ce qu'il ya c'est
mathématique l'oeil et des ressources
finies sa planète on peut pas toujours
utilisés c'est un concept que tu amènes
je ne me rappelle plus je crois que
j'étais coûtait dans le podcast des
ambassades
richard perdre le concept des ressources
finies qui trop souvent j'ai
l'impression dans la société de
consommation on a tendance à oublier ce
caractère finale qui existe réellement
le qu'on ignore juste parce que ça fait
peur juste parce que ce sont des mots
qui sont les modes de vie qui ne veut
pas habitués nous priver de quoi que ce
soit
dans l'abondance surtout ici en accident
puis c'est mathématique comme je disais
il ya des ressources qui sont finies
donc il faut trouver des moyens de faire
autant avec moins de ressources ou de
consommer moins tout simplement j'ai
l'impression que même les modèles
économiques sont basés sur la croissance
infinie tout ça c'est puis le framablog
étudiants business puis c'était comme le
les présupposés aux côtés comme bonbons
nous sur un monde où les ressources sont
infinies le modèle six attaques le tout
en partant sur l'économie c'est
supposons que l'information est parfaite
que les agents soient parfaitement
rationnel oui tout va bien donc le
modèle d'une telle affaire mais dans
vraie vie l'information est pas parfaite
aussi j'ai mis ce que l'autre pense les
agences est parfaitement rationnel au
propre les décisions irrationnelles dans
vies tous les jours
seillier personne mais peut-être le
meilleur quelqu'un qui fait l'épicerie
quelques tristes kg
quel maillot c'est moins cher lequel un
impact moins grand sur l'a6 on commence
à quédillac social environnemental de
tous nos produits l'on serait peut-être
parfaitement rationnel mon est loin de
ça donc le modèle d'économie qu'on a
c'est le cas aujourd'hui c'est
l'économie classique ici ça c'est
vraiment ce qui mène à notre perte le
kiki basé sur des fondations qui sont
pas solides le g pauvre il a fait sur
papier encore une fois mathématiquement
super élégant
tu penses tu poses quelques du compte
sur une base par exemple si tu préfères
arabe et puis je préfère b à ses formes
une ré a assez c'est logique
ouais ou que si tu aimes quelque chose
de vos préférées dans une cavité plus
grande de cette chose là que moins grand
temps que tu parles quelques actions de
base comme ça puis les modèles il se
développe dans toute une société mais si
c'est que cette rationalité l'on
l'appelle randonnée quand on est humain
oui et c'est ce qui fait que ces modèles
économiques leur pour faire des
politiques publiques basées purement là
dessus de ça mais nain au système
connaît ce moment de surconsommation
surproduction inégalités de richesse
incroyable
il continue de croître 19 cents à eux
parce qu'ils avaient passé 100 pays
ouais il faut vraiment changer notre
façon de voir le monde au conflit et est
ce que dans ton parcours touati qui qui
qui est un policier plus de gauche s'y
piquer des que des valeurs plus
justement de gauche dans tes études ou
dans ton travail d'être frustré par
ces modèles où passe cette façon de voir
l'économie
en fait ça m'a fait décrocher un
doctorat en économie pour un hyper
content parce que je me suis rendu
compte après 8 en 2009 à l'université
étudier actuellement finances économie
j'avais à tanger manta turbo chômage ou
une égalité ou tout ça c'est tout le
temps d'hellemmes des théorèmes puis des
choses mathématiques qui s'applique par
la suite mais ce n'est qu'en m'ennuie un
peu donc avant de finir le doc / venus
travailler ici ça pas vraiment en fait
mathématiciens et statisticiens pour
aimer l'économie moderne tels que
l'ancien parce que c'est vraiment que
des mathématiques et moins coûteux et
plus beaucoup d'économie politique
d'histoire de l'économie d'être pensée
économique et tout ce qui était plus
proche de la sociologie puis le
finalement de l'anthropologie puis de
quelque chose d'un peu plus du ministre
wen - à moi je pense qu'il faut étudier
dans d'autres départements qu'économie
pour avoir soi c'est ce qui fait que des
grosses corporations aussi plus plus la
structure devient grosse - l'humanité et
présente quelques mots les
multinationales plus au fait que les ca
deviens qui étaient des gens que leur
travail les économistes d'en garder les
chiffes puis de développer des modèles
comment qu'on peut croître encore plus
allez y et puis quelqu'un qui a un
regard acquis mais à travers tout ça est
ce que dit ce qui est ce que les humains
sont bien traités 3 2 que les ressources
sont bien faites qui considère beaucoup
une catégorie d'humains si leurs
actionnaires
ouais sauf que c'est une bonne façon de
voir les choses puisque pour ça que je
passais au chantier l'économie sainement
en panne à peu près trois ans jehad au
risque ce que j'ai fait là puisque je
voyais la passe et des entreprises qui
sont des business au même titre qu'une
inc en bourse donc écrit la même
richesse mais le nombre d'emplois mais
c'est des entreprises collectives
biopôle actionnaires qu'un profit ces
réinvestis dans l'entreprise ou dans la
collectivité
ce qui fait que la répartition des
richesses est bien meilleure il n'y a
pas de délocalisations d'emplois
c'est ce que tu dis ce que tu exprimes
elle sur calcul que pour les
actionnaires on va faire points 5 % de
rendement de plus en allant en malaisie
plutôt keita coaticook
ils vont le faire parce que c'est les
actionnaires qui disait que la marche
alors qu un obnl ou une coopérative donc
l'économie sociale qui fait la même
business avec les mêmes emplois puis la
même richesse va pas s'en aller en
malaisie pour points 5 % de rendement
plus parce qu'ils aient peu
d'actionnaires qui va exiger ça nous
vivons garder la mission à collectivités
puis vont rester là simplement donc ce
genre d'économie leur qui est très forte
au québec d'ailleurs l'économie sociale
on est des leaders mondiaux
genre d'économie l'asse une bonne partie
de la solution pour l'humanité des
prochaines années certains puisque dans
le fond souhaitait quitter londres pour
pour cette ce travail
la dernière fois où je suis revenu pour
le chantier fait qu'il ait travail qu'il
faisait à londres est-ce que c'était
dans ces domaines là où ce n'est plus là
non division la grande banque dans le
mondial j'étais pas dans le côté
spéculatif par contre jamais fait de la
finance dite spéculative de cette rue
cadet soit géré des fonds de pension au
moment où aider les gens à gérer des
fonds de pension ou faire des modèles
mathématiques encore pour ceux qui
gèrent des fonds de pension donc pour
gérer le risque la corrélation entre
classes d'actifs et tout ça donc j'ai
jamais dans la finance que je dirais
diabolique moi mais j'étais quand même
une catégorie de la finance qui mène à
un modèle qu'il faut vraiment éliminer
ou changer le sujet jamais été dense
catégorie là donc les spéculateurs qui
vont mettre une devise à terre pour
faire de l'argent mais ça met le pays en
ruines pendant 15 ans j'avais fait ça
donc ce jus par contre je travaillais à
londres dans la city là aussi un peu la
capitale mondiale de la finance donc et
c'est sûr que les valeurs qui sont là
c'est moins les valeurs d'économie
sociale les valeurs de au plus fort la
poche puis sitôt bonus est plus gros on
demande à voir - donc il faut que je
fasse attention à doha job qu'il y avait
peut-être un peu plus de rivalité
en général la city mais moi mes
collègues étaient acquis hors québec
lors tout toi non plus tu es allée des
années 90 j'ai bu pour les jours les
études puis long des années 90 c'était
quand même scène assez assez incroyable
en termes de la culture punk la contre
culture est long de neige londonienne
londonienne londonien je dire encore
aujourd'hui des affaires ou parce que sa
soeur de new york
mais ça sort de l'ombre à new york après
les britishs trous qui sont extrêmement
créatif a fait tout pour qu'ils
ressemblent beaucoup aux québécois sur
deux choses au moins la musique est
libre où le cynisme le maire gilbert
capitale c'est par tête de pipe le
nombre d'humoristes qui est la base d'un
prix comparable au québec ou dans ma
force cultuelle
et la musique aussi sont très créatifs
prix québécois aussi j'ai vu des
spectacles dans bien des pays le plus on
est les meilleurs buteurs au monde est
si convaincu on est vraiment top
on a 2 2 me fais de la musique dans les
po tang est ici j'ai pas le temps de la
mia parce que j'allais je fais je suis
guitariste sur le thème la comédie
musicale mamma mia c'est erding et la
musique royale avait tout à perdre et on
piano piano
montana maison familiale amicale est
celle qui est mal finalement
mais je prenne au numérique chez nous à
88 ans avec des bons mécanismes de mal
tout seul mais dans l'électronique parce
que j'aime bien
ouais effectivement est ce que est ce
que tu joues encore beaucoup activement
groupe à 12h jusqu'à un tel talent mais
c'est ça avec la job
pili job parce que j'ai quelques mandats
en ce moment avec les jobs les enfants
la famille et j'ai très peu de temps
pour pratiquer mais d'exane et je m'en
vais au piano parce que parce que si
j'avais un talent dans la musique parce
que j'en fais très peu pour que mes
compositions sont excellentes pour
combler mais c'est quand même pu dire
pour un t1 politique et du succès un
économiste du succès mais mon plus grand
talent c'est légitime mais je pense en
fait lorsque c'est ce qui m'intéresse le
plus
la passion est objectivement si j'avais
mis huit heures par jour en musique
toute ma ville je leur ai vraiment fait
quelque chose de propre et parce que je
mets vraiment quelques minutes par mois
et un jour je publierai seule vidéo qui
réduit canada fait sur ton jeu de piano
vu d'ailleurs qui sait ce qu est une des
tentes où tu te jouer du piano jeunes
purent l'impression que ça ça nous
quitte jamais vraiment ce qu'on en fait
vraiment jeune ça c'est ça conseil des
formules sur une certaine façon on peut
apprécier la musique nous suivent sèche
convainc culture que ça développe une
partie du cerveau qui se développe pas
avec le moins assez les mathématiques
des matières de base à l'école chez nous
on est trois enfants on était forcés les
trois faire des musiques
c'était peut-être mon père qui était un
musicien frustré de pas l'avoir été
parce qu'il avait beaucoup la musique
mais il jouait pas ma mère était prof
aux primaires de musique qu'on avait un
environnement quand même assez musical
puis nous forçait la version politique
de mon père c'était le pied d'eau ou bon
pied dans le derrière choisi le piano
ça descend ça c'est violent sa force est
chez nous ça votre part et d'autre mais
en farine moi quand je leur dis depuis
on va commencer on commençait à voir en
huit ans c'est un groupe homogène qui
ont huit ans et a commencé chez elle un
peu mais je vais forcer mois jusqu'à fin
de secondaire puis comme moi je pense
que dans dix vingt trente ans ils vont
venir d'avoir fait mais c'est souvent ce
qui se passe chez moi mettons j'ai fait
de la natation longtemps dans ma vie
puis au début je le faisais parce que
moi j'ai trois piliers que moi qui les
trois ans faisait web parce que ma mère
était tellement au foyer s'occuper de
nous quatre
puis quand qu'on allait aux cours de
natation tout le mondial est fait cas
juste décidé que moi j'en faisais aussi
depuis longtemps ça a été relativement
une corvette c2 forte des fois ça me
tente et des 60 ans témoin mais à chaque
fois c'est un peut me pousser à faire ce
jusqu'au moment où admirer ce crime
j'aime / puis je remercie grandement
mamère plus principalement maman mais
mes parents de m'avoir fort ses ennuis
mais à force ce qui ce dans quoi
maintenant je réalise que j'ai un talent
pixi j'avais commencé plus tard je serai
pas tu ne me serais pas rendue où il
s'est rendu le moins exacts l'utilisent
club-école samedi dimanche à gonesse
mois à chaque à chaque entraînement je
trouve une excuse pour sortir les
piscines je disais que je lai plus je me
soutenait avec le coach jusqu'à temps
qu'ils acquittent pas sûr si je m'étais
cibula ma serviette et coach plutôt
véhicule l'autre côté ouest et en région
qiangba quand ils te stinco froid
jusqu'à temps que tu le laisse sortir je
devais être insupportable mais je pense
que je me convient je sais combien mon
cerveau il avait d'abord frappé ouvrir
mais même pour la musique c'est le
critère parfaite du menteur pas te le
dis mais même sur la musique mais par
amour mon escrime ont pas forcé métier
m'encourager fortement à pratiquer même
que ce système qui domine est que pour
faire le phare le piano et veut toujours
eu un petit stage à chaque fois tu vois
je n'aurai pas le tiges arrêter le psg
joue du piano de 7 à 12 ans à peu près
j'ai arrêté parce que j'ai commencé la
guitare puis j'aurais pas je réponds la
musique aujourd'hui je n'avais pas été
inscrit de tianjin parce que ça m'a
aussi donné un bagage que la prison est
arrivé au cégep l'ico information dit
yves crime j'ai de la facilité commencé
quand j'ai fait du piano quand j'avais 7
ans et ton nom propre espace et lucide
oui de méprise pas jaloux s'il faut je
publie ma musique un jour ouais ouais
personne d'autre qui l'a entendu c'est
sûr qu'ils aient juste web pour
enregistrer un album piano seul ou en
fait dans une soixantaine des compos qui
sont prêtes moi il ya la plupart c'est
par la musique que des ordinateurs chez
nous avec des vicente chucho un peu
depeche mode
moi je pratiquerai très longue 90 le
très très longue cavale ils sont
toujours sans plus chauds puis adapté à
notre époque mais
dans les harmonies ses doigts et espérer
des années 80 est nommée jeune homme m
et 2,20 très bien marché attend encore
des nouveaux qui sont est-ce que tu
allais voir dépêche monde dernièrement
scrutin j'ai vu deux ou trois fois mais
la dernière fois c'est de faire 7 8 ans
qui sont venus et sont venus en fait le
2 1 c'est un petit bouquet de foi sont
au festival d'été de québec puis j'ai vu
au centre bell il ya quelques jours l'un
des meilleurs shows j'ai vu de ma vie
puis j'en ai fait un paquet quelque
chose et je trouve la musique est
excellente les visuels excellent les 2
go dans un show vous pouvez pas nier
québec et les warriors excellent
sénateurs qui était marqué dans mon
calendrier du la programmation de
spécialités sais pas comment ils vont
faire le visuel ses plaines d'abraham
pas ce qui est moindre
parce qu'avec la logistique de choses
qui m'ont beaucoup beaucoup le fait
qu'ils sont surprenants dans leur
capacité à s'adapter aux artistes
laitiers taillon sur rammstein plusieurs
fois puis comme ça il ya même ya bien le
rapport show l'onglet le même temps les
camions qui avaient en arrière du state
c'était des treasuries mais eux aussi
ont su mieux maintenant de choc le
visuel très important muse est rangement
il y avait le comme les quatrièmes
membres du band que j'ignorais
complètement l'existence ni apparemment
reste toujours dans l'ombre parce qu'il
était dans l'ombre du ciac tournée
engagés sous mon nom c'est comme un
membre officiel le mieux loti vie était
carrière derrière lui non c'était pas le
business et le teich pour que tu fais à
billettes en avant ouais c'est ça qui
sera tourné aussi pas de soi c'est le
droit qui donnait pas perdre tout aussi
noir il passé le chanteur qui compose
tout qui va tout va c'est un peu la même
chose que les blacks qui les blacks qui
jouaient ce que tu as comme un gars qui
a l'air d'être un jeans complet puis on
le droit moral je suis très choquée
c'est pourquoi ils sont deux
black is il vraiment moyen le tempo ça
bouge à y veiller à la série mais tu
vois mais black is henchoz lyon 2 onuci
de tourner mais moi je pensais que des
compositions c'était bien nous car il
est tout à fait j'en ai beaucoup aussi
jouer au sol ops et néoclassiques kiwi
d'alinghi de jean michel baylet donc
j'en ai pas mal aux pieds notre seul
mais quand j'ai des textes qui me
viennent je fais sur détonne un peu plus
orchestré un peu de chance ou si je
charge de fausses promesses si j'avais
publié ça ce serait pas mal
ok ok j'ai pas de tribologie brad hawpe
a une belle voix de chantage que sa note
mais c'est un peu mais jean leloup non
plus il lui faut une personne d'autre
des chanteurs qui fausse bien je parle
pas spécifiquement le chanteur de the
cure
on a bossé affreusement puisse t bonds
paris ce qu'il faisait avec une bonne
façon de kurt cobain y était et est
rarement direct dessus lyrique c'est moi
je pense pas que tu as besoin d'avoir
une belle voix njimi de la manière
classique on attend se voit pauvre est
chanteur personnalisé qui pourrait être
autant qu'on peut être juste se croire
puis se trouvait pape et même si
objectivement on n'est pas chanteur
lyrique fait que j'ai la tête quelqu'un
qui a une vraie belle voix contre la
musique que je trouve ma boîte quoi un
jour de ben un jour d'ab inbev juste
voie parce que c'est déjà tout programme
qui s'appuie sur ce tacle il ne tourne
pas bien au chaud c'est ce si un jour je
démissionne sa présence serait vraiment
ce match est vraiment important oui à
tout je serais vraiment curieux est
content d'entendre c'est moi depuis
toute noire que mac et ma curiosité ne
fait qu'augmenter le plus on en parle au
début j'étais comme j'ai vraiment cru
entendre des compositions bleus ah ouais
inspiré de depeche mode ok avec des
paroles hockey
alex était plus jeune c'était en anglais
faut être conséquent le poker et les
beats des baux était meilleur anglais
c'est sûr mais c'est difficile quand que
nous référence nous influençons
anglophones c'est pas tout ce qui se
transpose bien d'une langue à l'autre
en fait je trouve que c'est parce qu'on
comprend vraiment très bien ce qu'on dit
moi il chantait tout croche en anglais
ça passe magnifique de marcoule gard à
nîmes at il fait un principe ça donne un
style qu'il faut vraiment assumé ouais
et y émettant celui qui fait la tournée
immortelle en album posthume
comment s'appelle
les sports tueur h là que je lai bref un
bateau ne chante pas bien mais c'est
beau c'est un chef-d'oeuvre est
objectivement il chante pas très bien
donc quatre os a subi qu'on se trouve
bon ça ça parait que les jeunes soient
wiki pomme au coca chante c'est oui mais
voilà j'écoutais des vidéos l'autre jour
de gilles vigneault super jeune chanteur
justement qu'un quand ils disent croire
il arrivait sur le plateau c'était comme
un émission ce pas trop pire il opine t
il fort au spi meeschaert piste donne
puisque roy briller dans tpiy le fait
qu'ils kiki aussi confiant pardonne ses
erreurs et pas de voix de chanteurs du
tout mais c'est excellent c'est sur le
dernier album de serge fiori moi c'était
ce que je me dis aussi les échos ok
c'est sûr mais on dirait que j'embarque
pas du tout dans le dans la voix comme
tel à savoir très spécifique mais moi je
n'embauche un grand fan mais tu suis sûr
que sa voix avec le temps c'est ce exact
c'était comme l'espèce des c'est le
teint on s'entendait plus que que là tu
la vois comme tel c'est ce que yang
ripertm de voix très spécifiques ceux
qui ont vécu l'époque historique et moi
j'ai pas le cg harmonium j
j'ai adoré quand je l'écouté un t1 après
la pré coûté 2 pas vraiment vivent ce
mouvement le réellement promet que j'ai
pas le même affaire
quand j'entends que l'afsset voile haute
et même moi je te donnais un peu trop
tard pour les grandes et d'harmonium
c'est plus mes parents qui ont peut-être
vécu ça je me suis mis et bébé d'abord
germanium schéma grave mais c'est pas
fait pour la musique qui jouait à radio
même temps qu'un car moi j'avais 15 ans
un harmonium est imparfait ségou et va
vers la culture québécoise je trouve le
si on veut basculer un peu dans ce je
trouve que harmonium quand tu écoutes
par exemple sur ce portefeuille sur la
peau music des playlists
2 maintenant les essentiels du prog est
toujours des taux normaux mondialement
comme un fleuve le sont tout le temps
dans le top 5 tout le temps énorme
considéra que cet instant français si
c'est ça il faisait abstraction de la
langue qui regardaient la musique des
variations en modulation tout ça c'est
pas ça c'est pas moins bon que genesis
ou de maintenance exactement c'est
vraiment moi quand j'ai eu ma femme
armani mamani je tombais l'inde à pic je
travaillais cherchant beau quand j'étais
plus jeune pis j'avais artiste album
loti je mets mon frère m'avait dit que
aulas qui l'a peut-être d'harmonieuses
classe et ses peluches jeux les justes
sur la tablette je les prix kloet et ce
encore l'époque et ma mère venait me
chercher avec les animaux chercher puis
le seront dans le rouge mais ce qui
c'était un coup de poing en face puis
j'ai eu une période que j'écoutais que
german de l'état où l étape l'état
depuis intimité je connaissais les îles
classées comme tout le monde je
connaissais les pièces les plus connues
bref je résiste et les autres qui moi
c'est vraiment riche
justement le premier je trouve bon 12e
très bon le troisième un du pur génie
c'est vraiment une nouveauté les niveaux
des orchestrations vous musical
s'assagissent aucun aucun bon sens mais
à watou ils vont en fait atteint au
niveau des textes au niveau de l'émotion
qui passe au niveau des compositions de
l'arrangement tout est bon au niveau de
l'engouement quand ils l'écoutent
ouais c'est notre budget a dit en
entrevue et 10 k pour composer sa il
faisait juste japonais le plus notable
passé mais quelque chose qui n'est
possible
j'avais joué jouer les sections en
boucle est encore en boucle il y avait
une phrase qui venait notre france pis
de toute la journée par la faille avant
tout c'est fou pareille époque mais en
fait ils à la musique québécoise rayonne
encore tout autant
et à l'international je dirais autant
que j'aimais surtout nous voir en fait
les voix québécois sont très recherchés
en france ce sont anne est d'ailleurs
tout le chanteur qui marchent choix des
québécois en général qu'aux filles mais
que j'attends tout je pense qu'au québec
on a mis en mission bon j'ai vu des
choses comme je disais à peu près tous
les pays touchés allier un touriste ou
pour le job pilleurs on est haïti si ces
foules d'amateurs et copines quelqu'un
vraiment est on est vraiment dans les
doux et en musique puis si c'est
vraiment une scène musicale puis est
vraiment quelque chose de books créé une
effervescence pitié qui je pense aussi
qu'elle est il ya un bon système pour
encourager les autres compositeurs qui
émerge puis ceux qui commencent
seulement depuis la culture c'est
nécessaire a fait passer rentable dans
l'ensemble la culture mais quand tu
prends un spectacle lui-même
ça prend de l'aide pour qu'il soit
rentable que tout ce qui est en
périphérie tout le monde qui travaillent
dessus visée par la salle les
techniciens les restaurateurs tout ça un
investissement qui chipera tabac bout de
ligne dollars à culture vaut bien plus
que dollars dans l'économie après mais
il y en a qui équipe la navy grosses
capis regarde le choc qui disent sans
subventions ça marcherait pas et dbs de
luxe ouais ça c'est pas tellement
comprendre comment ça marche l'économie
c'est c'est vraiment
[Musique]
une nuance extrêmement intéressante de
dame n'est pas ce qu'on a déjà eu la
conversation par rapport à aux
subventions culturelles avec avec
françois lambert qu'on a reçues sur le
podcast hours sans abri colombie
probablement plus mais le point que tu
es un d'amener par rapport à toutes les
répercussions en périphérie d'un d'une
oeuvre artistique ça c'est pas un point
que j'avais considéré nécessairement
dans mon magasin et ça c'est le côté
économique mais juste le côté la beauté
exact
c'était le point sociales ont remis un
peu plus loin faire dépasser c'est ce
faut pas oublier que c'est une valeur
une grande valeur c'est qui qui qui -
qui est pas quantifiable en chef passing
de dollars mais cui qui la plus
importante c'est plus grande et social
plus grande égalité l'équilibré meilleur
je passe les arts sont essentielles dans
n'importe quelle société économique
le pack culture s'assurer que les teams
c'est ça revient les questions en bout
de ligne c'est pourquoi on ville c est
ce qu on vit pour pour n'être travailler
travailler travailler faire de l'argent
puis il peut mourir notre football qu'un
peu de beauté en soirée il dit je pense
que ce sont points son point principal
était celui des étais pas contre les
subventions alors qu'ils étaient pour
une un niveau de rendement nécessaire
avant de justifier les subventions
c'est à dire qu'il ya beaucoup de jury
de pairs qui choisissent qui donc il
faut une qualité puis pour quelque chose
qui est las de ces postes peu aléatoire
tout artiste de l'argent public système
qui fait que lui critiqué lui je pense
qu'ils montrent un petit peu un argument
un épouvantail qui détruisait après le
maîtriser et les émissions radio canada
qui a personne qui écoute l'après midi
puis c'est faux le subventionner et puis
il ya cinquante personnes qui écoutent
ça peu de bon sens dans la vie je suis
vraiment premièrement juste cinquante
personnes qui écoutent y ait vraiment
aux dites vraiment en ce sens a dit
qu'il pensait et que j'ai l'impression
qu'ils attaquaient quelque chose que je
sais même pas s'ils existent façon on
pourrait dire
et bien des livres qui sont essentiels
que programme en lui et il le devoir et
peut aussi lire le journal de montréal
ce qui suggère qu'on ferme le devoir
parce que c'est pas assez populaire de
voir un autre créneau que le journal de
montréal il va plus à fond dans certains
dossiers que le journal montréal et vice
versa donc c'est vraiment une diversité
qu'il faut garder le diversifier les
sources d'information de culture de tous
donc le fait que l'audimat soit plus bas
ce n'est pas un argument pour dire qu'il
faut le faire c'est peut-être plus utile
que l'audimat champions l'as relatifs
mais c'est sûr que ça lui fera soit oui
c'est vrai on était c'est un garçon dans
lequel on des 95% en accord avec ce
qu'on est pas d'accord avec lui quand il
est tombé plus à l'afp à la fin de ce
podcast qu'on me parlait plus politique
plus justement subvention de ce que l'on
me dit de faire arrêter sinon je
saisirai
il y est dit était bon à chacun dans
moneyweek définitivement mais ça c'est
quelque chose qui m'intéresse en deux
économistes de gauche est souvent
capable puis j'ai écouté une coupe d'été
entrevue puis que de tes commentaires
par rapport à plusieurs sujets est
souvent capable de retourner un argument
de la droite
un point de vue économique team
admettons qu'on compare la souveraineté
beaucoup d'arguments de nacional por
nationalisme et fédéraliste beaucoup
d'arguments fédéraliste tourne autour de
l'économie et des haricots et des peurs
économique exact puis je dire est dans
toutes les conversations que j'ai eues
par rapport aux au souverainisme les
arguments qu'on m'envoyait des arguments
économiques mais la beauté d'avoir une
personne comme toi qui est capable
d'avoir la parole dans la place publique
par rapport à ces questions là c est
capable de de prendre ces arguments
économiques club de durban
en vérité du ctu quoi ça serait de
l'autre façon c'est l'argument que vous
utilisez un argument est l argument
exactement un argument fallacieux puits
qui se trouve c'est intéressant parce
qu'on a souvent tendance à à mettre
l'économie avec la droite mais selon
thomas tiquement web est ainsi plus
mathématique ou plus structurée ça va
souvent tiré par réflexe les gens ceci
c'est à la droite mais la question à
savoir si on sera plus riches aux plus
pauvres sont est un pays
les petits pays dans le monde sont les
pays les plus riches y a pas un pays qui
veut laisser sa souveraineté puis
fusionner claude pays pour donner plus
riches ça marche pas c'est un service
tafalla l'argument final et fédérales et
c'est souvent la péréquation
ouais il nous disait c'est un gros
chèque de péréquation est encore aux
dépens du canada est ce qu'ils disent
pas c'est que père capitaux reçoit le
plus petit chèque de péréquation dames
en 1 8 million et demi au québec ne
multiplient ce pour n'importe quel
chiffre ça donne un gros chèque
mais parmi les provinces qui reçoivent
donc à vous toutes les provinces n'ont
pas de pétrole reçoivent la péréquation
c'est vraiment du pétrole vers le nom
pétrole la péréquation c'est pas des
bons vers l'est pas bon ce qui est par
hasard avait du pétrole sur le
territoire et ont plus de capacité
fiscale
donc si on regarde le chèque de
péréquation par personne au québec on en
reçoit moins que les autres car soi et
en plus la péréquation et comme
compensation partielle parce que ça me
coûte d un système là parce qu'on envoie
chaque année des dizaines de milliards
de nos impôts à l'extérieur du québec ce
qui est extérieur du québec à se
développer plus vite évidemment les
dizaines de milliards puis ensuite
on trouve qu une capacité plus grande de
nous aider donnez moi la moitié de ton
salaire à ton voisin chaque année ça
m'étonnerait pas qu'il ait une plus
grosse piscine que toi avant longtemps
et qui est malade il faudrait peut-être
juste car ils votent pour les mérites et
pourtant vous changez le système pas ce
que parce que tu vas gagner québec
garder ses designers ici puis qui
investissaient par exemple des énergies
renouvelables au lieu des sables
bitumineux
parce que c'est nos impôts qui financent
et sables bitumineux albertains données
sont investis dans ce qui va être les
énergies d'avenir depuis qu'on sait déjà
on pourrait même exporter sa s'enrichit
aider la planète hockey plein avantages
économiques et environnementaux à ce que
le québec soit pays je pense qu'on vécu
ses arguments 3 je les entends les dix
ont montré qu on les entend pas aussi
clairement aussi simplement
kitty mois
dentelle dans le coin 2012 avec ce qui
s'est passé avec les carrés otcbb skpi
quittons discours avec option nationale
l'époque ça a été un petit peu pour moi
un jour d'éveil aux politiques mais dont
je me souviens que c'est ce qui m'avait
frappé à quel point justement un nouveau
discours une nouvelle phase on parle de
souveraineté que j'avais jamais entendu
parce qu'on l'ait convaincu les gens les
gens qui sont attachés qu'ils sentent
québécois qui sont attachés à cette
culture loops qui sont souveraineté pour
c'est pour des raisons plus émotionnelle
et affective sentimentale et romantique
oui c'est ça les romans six sont déjà
convaincu les indécis ils pensent plus à
leur portefeuille savait exactement mais
d'avoir un politicien de gauche
souverainiste qui tient ce discours le
pic il faut aller chercher ces personnes
neuf trous ce super important spa
inspirante et puis moi je suis convaincu
comme toi que ceux qui sont plus
sentimentaux ou romantiques sont déjà
pas mal en faveur du oui au référendum
demain matin si les pragmatiques qu'il
faut aller chercher
et pourtant il ya eu des gens qui s'y
connaissent est autrement plus que moi
d'économies avant droite monsieur
parizeau branlant drizzt des grands
pédagogues l'économie aussi on dirait
que le discours qui perçait c'était
quand même de disco culturel discours
historique
ces choses là qui allaient chercher une
bonne frange de la population mais qui a
fait son que plafonné ouais si on veut
que le oui parce qu'un jour il faut
garder cela puis aller chercher les
pragmatiques en bonne partie oui c'est
un discours plus économique qui va les
amener plus environnemental plus
internationaliste les jeunes aujourd'hui
affecté les cultures québécoise ils
l'aiment bien mais s'identifie pas
d'abord québécois y en a qui trouvent
citoyens du monde attend ça fait je
trouve ça bizarre comme concept nous
[ __ ] toi tu viens pour des citoyens
demandent je sais pas mais même s'ils
pensent à eux qu'est ce qui est ce qui
est le plus à même où le mieux à même
d'être un citoyen du monde quelqu'un qui
dans un pays qui parle de cette province
qui fait parler en son nom par un autre
pays et je vais le présenter au tam
international du tout ce qu'ils veulent
et de soins du monde devrait être en
faveur d'un québec pays logiquement t
puis ça c'est super important jeu thomas
surtout qu'un que
pu demander fois quand dit souverainiste
ou nationale est surtout avec la
connotation qui ce molosse en europe qui
peut être rapidement vu comme un ferme
et à l'autre la session alice vraiment
même le parti le front national parce
que mon nationale et bojan nationale
l'assemblée nationale nationale nos
bobos mais en europe c'est un peu en
lady à cause de la politique des
dernières décennies et le nationalisme
attisé le mot nazi vient du bon
nationaliste nationalisme en allemand
aussi donc c'est maintenant qu'il ya eu
des exams qu'il l'aura du un peu moins
sexy mais ici nationalisme au port mais
le vent a pas encore cette connotation
là il ya certains qui s'y opposent qui
vont essayer de la donner
c'est ça mais je sais la liste ça peut
juste être patriote et être fier de ce
qu'ont fait bien de nos racines et tout
ça c'est positif comme au national
je suis d'accord avec ça mais j'ai
l'impression que
cette critique long là on l'a on
l'entend plus ou à à commence à
s'instaurer le sait cette association le
surtout avec des figures de style des
figures de droite au québec très
nationalistes comme me thomas thibaud
côté ou d'autres qui qui qui amène parce
que tu es au québec je crois que la
souveraineté soins étaient plus associé
à la gauche avec le pq puis avec la pop
au centre plus à gauche quelques à toi
mais l'oeil aussi espèce de nouvelle
droite nationaliste qui commencent à
apparaître et tantôt faut aller chercher
à la fois les romantiques et les
pragmatiques faut aussi aller chercher à
la fois la gauche et la droite ce que
personne dans son groupuscule qui est
suffisant pour avoir 50 heures pour ça
au moins 65 pour ça qu'on voudrait pour
sa part donc il faut aller chercher tout
le monde qui la souveraineté c'est
objectivement signé à gauche ni à droite
le fait de choisir nous mêmes ce qu'on
fait chez nous de contrôler tous nos
lois tous nos impôts tous nos traités
avec qui on s'aimait traités signés à
gauche ni à droite quel pays qui en
résultent vaut faire la voix alterner
entre la gauche et la droite à chaque
élection comme partout dans le monde aux
états unis la grande bretagne en
allemagne en france et alterne tout à
centre gauche centre droite section
alors on sera pas différent là dessus
une erreur aussi que certains
souverainistes font c'est de dire on
veut la souveraineté si c'est à gauche -
quelque chose de totalement illogique à
dire on veut vous donner la liberté à
condition que la liberté ce soit ce jeu
puis la liberté c'est plus la liberté
rendue à la liberté au peuple de choisir
s'ils votent à gauche ou à droite puis
un bon démocrate dont l'acceptent
moi je préférais qu'un québec souverain
soit plutôt centre gauche gauche parce
que je pense que communauté qui se tient
puis qui voit tout le monde c'est mieux
pour l'égalité sociale et tout mais si
jamais le québec était souverain depuis
que j'ai réalisé un gouvernement de
centre-droite pendant 18 ans je
déménagerai pas pour ça je militerai
pour que ça revienne à gauche et two way
est la liberté devrait être plus
important que de dire cela vote à gauche
sinon je milite pas où ça va être à
droite n'ont jamais il faut se donner
les moyens d'être à gauche ou à droite
mais cette excuse moi continuer la
formule que j'utilisais c'est avant
d'être à gauche ou d'être à droite il
faut être un pilote choisi rester à
gauche qu'à droite pour l'instant on
n'est pas
et on est subordonné décide pas nous
mêmes le plus grand défi en ce moment
puisque jamais été fait
c'est de ramener tout le monde sous une
même bannière c'est sous une même somme
un mouvement peace parce que justement
entre le militant ghazi extrême gauche
de chez québec solidaire aux
souverainistes de droite
c'est idiot de le dire on va s'unir puis
on veut trop bien sûr une fois de l'adq
et le pq a réussi à faire ses débuts
avec l'évêque même caucus il y avait des
gens de gauche des gens de droite puis
même quand j'ai été élu en 2008 avec les
pq dans même caucus il y avait mon écrit
charles ancien syndicaliste puis
françois legault l'homme d'affaires qui
étaient là pour la souveraineté tout le
monde même si tu es de gauche ou de
droite
je pense que le problème qu'a eue avec
un parti comme le pq c'est quand arrête
de parler de souveraineté comme causes
premières et les autres débats qui prend
la place c'est le pc les serveurs dont
ça se clive alors que quand tout le
monde parle de souveraineté tout le
monde est uni donc un parti
souverainiste doit parler de
souveraineté pour que son caucus reste
cohérent non c'est sa savane à des
débats qui en sorte que les désaccords
sont les plus vite c'est moins équilibré
mais tant pis le discours de dire on va
parler de souveraineté le prochain
mandat
c'est pas un discours non plus qui qui
intéresse les personnes qui veulent
parler de souveraineté au moment où est
cependant si on a refroidi quelques uns
puis pour être honnête la stratégie de
monsieur liste n'est pas de parler
c'était de l'après paris puis de la
faire au mandat d'arrêt parce que si ça
avait été de ne pas parler moi je
n'aurais même pas été candidat en 2018
la stratégie c'était justement de
refaire toutes les études pour montrer
que sur le plan environnemental
financier l'eau matic sur tous les plans
on avait tout avantage et de souverains
ou du moins on espérait que les études
donnerait sa passe qui aurait été
objective les études avaient déversé
époux
on veut pas que le québec s'en aille
dans un bureau en plus elle l'idée
c'était de préparer tout ça pour que
d'en revendre après ce soit basé
frontalement comme il disait le train il
y en a qui trouvait que c'était pas
assez pressé et d'autres qui vont
toujours trouvé que c'est trop rapide
c'est pas sympa politique faire passer
dix jours mon poids est vraiment
complexe mais
j'ai toujours été de l'avis qu'on se
présente en disant exactement ce qu'on
veut faire tout de suite et on reste les
lecteurs au juge et l'image que
j'utilise souvent à l'époque cécile et
si le parti vert disait on voit tes lui
pendant un mandat me fera pas de
développement durable parce que les gens
soient pas encore la deuxième partie
non c'est notamment il faut quand on est
fédéraliste politique a tonné
souverainiste falls et puis je pense que
le jour où tous les partis vont avoir
aussi un cycle à le faire qu'est ce que
vous en dites là la population va se
réintéresser apolitique mais l'étude
les taux de participation aux élections
avoir ré augmenter à ce qu'ils étaient
avant à 80 pour sa voix soul man parce
que j'ai l'impression qu'elle est ya une
espèce de du moins pour ce pour ceux qui
suivent un peu la politique comme que
moi je la suis c'est à dire de façon un
peu lointaine ch pour la personne la
plus politiquement intéressés mais j'ai
l'impression qu'ils ingèrent de flou en
les parties un jardin une jarre de
souplesse de sa change pas grand chose
au final parce que pas il n'y a pas de
croyance ferme c est pas de pas de
position claire
je dirais qu'on est dans un niveau assez
bas d'intérêt général à la politique
probablement mais le gouvernement actuel
qui fait ce qui a failli il fait à peu
près ce que dit qui fait je ne peux pas
les critiquer là dessus mais il est élu
avec le prêtre en tête pour ça depuis
c'est le gouvernement majoritaire avec
les plus faibles appuis de l'histoire du
québec qui en fait si on compte le taux
d'abstention parce qu'ils ne sont pas
les votes et donc avec le taux
d'abstention il ya 25 % des gens qui ont
voté pour le cac
donc trois personnes sur quatre ont voté
autre chose ou sont pas allés voter et
on appelait ça quand même une vague
quand on va regarder des gens sont
pauvres
sénart et l'élu qui m'a fortement
majoritaire la cause du système qu'on
accepte aussi un corner de système
uninominal des élections donc le jeu
comprend que certaines personnes
regardent ça de loin puis se disent que
l'eau tellement représentatif d'ailleurs
je suis très content que monsieur
legault soit ouvert à changer le mode de
scrutin
j'ai bien confiance moi qui vont le
faire il faut parce que ça ça n'a pas de
sens quand on est démocrate de se dire
que trois personnes sur quatre autres
choses votre pop c'est quand même toi
qui est majoritaire
le mot majoritaire et comme tron par le
système
le temps passe et ça fait c'est ce qui
était décrypte surtout que l'ouverture
des bulletins le 1er octobre trois
minutes après c'était 4 majoritaire
c'est ça vraiment frappé tout le monde
c'est impressionnant quand même ce soir
il a un quand on regarde les chiffres
ils ont reçu l'appui de du quart des
électeurs inscrits il devrait peut-être
pas être ici majoritaire à l'assemblée
dans un système plus proportionnelle
puis comme je disais je félicite
françois legault est ouvert à changer ce
système là qui pour talent malgré une
victoire
ouais soi que je pense que les articles
à celui de rené lévesque disait tout le
temps on va le faire
il fait le faisait pour des raisons d
fois de calculs d'autrefois de
complexité puis faut dire qu'il veut
dire et faire à des meilleures au canada
aussi comme les britanniques qui ont
fait rêver la dame sur voulez vous
changer de système les gens votent et
dont on voulait garder le système actuel
s'expose pas simplifier le référendum au
québec est curieux de voir si les gens
majoritairement dirait qu'ils veulent
changer
justin trudeau le prochain jeu non plus
il avait dit qu'il ferait lui c'est sûr
ça a été ça a été tu peux citer des
raisons stratégiques mais ça des chemins
du monde c'est quand même l'être humain
et veut toujours changer les règles
jusqu'à peindre qui gagne selon ses
règles
c'est rené lévesque en fait il y avait
peut-être une raison stratégique de se
dire qu'on voulait pas de
proportionnelle parce que rené lévesque
était plus populaire que le pq pile pq
était plus populaire que souveraineté
s'il y avait eu des proportionnelle il a
peut-être prête au pouvoir alors que
maintenant c'est l'un vertes la
souveraineté dans les sondages est
encore d'aller 35% cac40 c'est
phénoménal au ca pital c'est le pôle erp
de ceux dans le discours public pas fait
la souveraineté actuelle est à peu près
plus haute que le gouvernement est lui à
quatre pour ça puis est plus élevé que
la popularité du pq la popularité du pq
plus élevé que son chef donc celle
inverse de l'époque l'évêque donc
maintenant si elle est proportionnelle
au québec qui aurait sans doute plus de
souverainistes l'assemblée nationale
auxonne et stratège
ouvrez liste on souhaite la
proportionnelle maintenant alors qu'à
l'époque c'était l' inverse
ok vous ayez plus des mauvaises raisons
avec vous il ya plus de raisons valables
de pau souhaité un système plus
proportionnel au québec quand on est
souverainiste mais là le projet de loi
pour changer ça ait été déposée trop
tard je pense pour les prochaines
élections il doit l'aider j'ai vécu a
dit que ça prendrait les délais de
plusieurs semaines quelques dizaines de
voix pardon auprès de moi donc il ya des
gens qui disent encore que si c'est
d'épouser la cl c'est très possible que
la prochaine surface comme ça ou
peut-être qu'il pourrait y avoir une
alarme d'hagrid a pas ce qu'on entend ça
si vous l'écoutez avec vos critiques
tablette ou peut-être qu'ils pourraient
par exemple dire à la prochaine élection
il va y avoir aussi une question par
référendum voulez vous un nouveau
système on est donc ça va lui permettre
d'avoir une autre élection d'un système
actuel ça serait peut-être de deuxième
mandat
je suis sûr que ces stratèges
réfléchisse à tous de façon aussi temps
aucun depuis sion si on s'éloigne un
petit peu de la politique puisse en
parler je veux qu'on parle dans le lien
que je voulais faire c'était on parle
beaucoup souveraineté de peter puis
dimensionner les ressources d'énergies
renouvelables qu'on a essayé d'énergie
verte dit on entend souvent on entend
souvent on entend des comparatifs avec
par exemple on dit le québec va être
l'arabie saoudite des ressources verte
on dit puis le c'est là que je m'en
allais vers les jeux vidéo ont dit que
le québec va devenir la silicon valley
des jeux vidéo
pis ces deux comparatif énorme pour
quelqu'un qui s'intéresse à l'économie
et au secteur aurait vraiment la
dotation naturel au québec c'est tout ce
qui est porteur pour l'avenir
on est en fait un des chantiers de parts
de pétrole on en avait eu on leur
expliquait comme n'importe quel autre
support c'est sûr que je trouve c'est ce
que je trouve intéressant
puis les énergies vertes que ce soit la
biomasse la géothermie le solaire
l'éolien tout ça de toute la dotation
ici au tac n'importe qui demandent si
non plus donc on est chanceux lathus
sauf que comme je dis on envoie nos
milliards d'investissements ailleurs
pour l'instant dans fédération laquelle
on est c'est un peu dommage mais sur le
plan de la créativité en fait dans le
prouve et nantes où la danse en théâtre
en musique on est parmi les peuples les
plus créatifs ou au monde
puis ça s'est su très bien dans les jeux
vidéo en fait si on regarde les trois
grandes plaques tournantes de jeux vidéo
dans le monde le japon il vraiment avec
la californie les grands studios de jeux
vidéo puis le ce qui complète le top 3
si le québec
ouais ouais ouais puis tous les grands
studios internationaux sont venus
s'installer ici d'ailleurs medef notre
inventivité environnement fiscal et des
au départ c'est sûr puis bernard landry
s'est lui ai fait projet de loi est
votée en fait les crédits d'impôt en
soutien à l'industrie du jeu vidéo
maintenant partout c'est extrêmement
avant gardiste est oui a été visionnaire
la tuque l'industrie le reconnaît
d'ailleurs l'industrie lui reconnaît la
paternité de secteur est ici mais ça a
été copié par tous deux n'ont donc
maintenant s'il québec enlever ces
crédits d'impôt là il se tirait d'appui
par tous les autres en ont mis président
a tiré le mans mais malgré ça c'est
quand même au québec que les gros
studios venait s'installer pour notre
qualité de main d'oeuvre
l'environnement général qui map qui vont
économique très stable et avant à mon
sens un secteur dont on n'a pas encore
fini de découvrir la possibilité parce
que et le côté divertissement évidemment
les jeux vidéo mais le côté
d'applications dans le domaine de la
santé de l'éducation de que les mêmes
programmes ap faire avec des applis
ouais donc le potentiel d'application
des jeux vidéo du côté ludique d'une
application mobile ou sur plateforme ou
sur pc c'est encore insoupçonnées je
pense que le québec beaucoup se
développer
j'ai participé à un
un tournage avec allô prof qui est une
espèce de truc qui a deux les enfants le
soir à l'école met en fait que tout le
temps des professeurs en ligne que tu
peux chatter avec les autres vraiment
ils ont fait une collaboration avec
conjugaux qui est un jeu de mobiles ou
est ce que tu es comme un bonhomme qui
saute sur des plateformes
puis il faut que tu passes dans des
genres de guides d achat qu à chaque
porte que tu traverses une question de
conjugaison du conjuguer un verbe donc
celtics a fait apprendre aux enfants des
choses qui voudrait pas faire parce que
couvrir sa place côté ludique qui
embarque depuis et même au pays
imaginaire d'applications ou par exemple
vous faire les exercices avec un oeil
pour l'entraîner à corriger un petit
défaut dans mon malgré un jeu vidéo qui
fait en sorte que l'enfant suit le
bonhomme ou le ballon dans le sens où il
faut que le tram 1 donc il ya plein
d'applications qui peuvent corriger des
choses se planquent objet de la santé
lutte contre le décrochage scolaire
donc moi je pense que si on pense que le
jeu vidéo atteint un certain plafond moi
je pense au contraire que les
possibilités sont infinies puis les
québec va tirer son épingle du jeu là
dedans parce que les lumières ressources
ici et on est déjà très fort là dedans
puis je pense qu on est très très ouvert
à l'innovation sociale par le jeu vidéo
on converse vraiment tout à espérer de
sa si les applications pour le langage
ou c'étaient des jeux prend des langues
jouer pour développer des
des sections de cerveau différentes
c'est vraiment sincèrement ce passé que
l'aspect ludique et donne l'impression
de s'amuser en faisant quelque chose
l'espèce de poids de trouver sa place
tout de tout ça disparaît dès que le
côté ludique à bach jeu vidéo à prendre
des instruments de musique même si
maintenant il ya des comme des lois si
c'était déjà des guitares oui mais avec
une régularité qui fait qu'il ait sauté
avec apprendre le piano au sipi qui
publie pour des parlers d'applications
dans la vraie vie au site il y avait
parlé cac et connaîtra jamais brûlé
week-end ça c'est cool avec ça s'inscrit
tout ça s'est fait tout le travail qui
avait fait avec notre dame de montréal
c'est sur exactement au real il y avait
tellement de détails le sommeil et la
structure en haut de notre dame qui
peuvent se fier au jeu pour essayer de
reconstituer 5 royal
assassin's creed si si je me trompe os
c'est quand même toute la franchise
depuis le premier c'est une plaque
tournante d'un jeu vidéo puis c'est un
produit de six mois je me rappelle j'y
jouais aux trois premiers comme vraiment
beaucoup apprécié j mais vire commencé à
prendre une autre tournure au refuge et
j'ai changé premièrement les jeux et
jouets puis j'ai au bridge à san jose
crabol avec mes amis en littérature
c'est fait mais ce jeu l'est sujet là
est une plaque tournante d'un jeu vidéo
attelage le g1 après assassins soient
vraiment jeux vidéo pc bush père fier
que c'était faire mourir oui en fait
quand les gens passent un succès de jeux
vidéo sur la planète
en fait j'ai beaucoup de québécois qui
savent même pas que c'était faux québec
ben oui mais qui joue à ceux qui savent
pas que c'est écrit ici ça lui sert de
moi je me rappelle à vinça ce screen
je jouais à prince of persia qui te fais
ici aussi puis souvent dans les jeux en
général quand j'entends je jouais puis
je mettais à version française c'était
souvent des voix fait en france qui me
rejoignait - quand j'ai joué à 'prince
of persia' version française
je me suis dit oui on crée on dirait que
c'est quelqu'un d'ici qui parle qui fait
les voix c'est le on dirait on dirait un
film québécois tiens on dirait que c'est
ça que changerait le fort puis après ça
je mettais un téléfilm j'ai fait en vain
si c'est ici le jeu que je passe tout
mon temps s'est pas faite aux états unis
s'est pas faite au japon s'est fait ici
beaucoup de bonne musique que je vis des
oui oui ils disent pas bon qu'on pousse
toi ki ké c'est souvent une des bonnes
façons de gagner sa vie maintenant quand
tu es tout tant qu'opposition pythie
être compositeur de deuil de concert ces
poèmes en musique de jeu vidéo commencer
début oui cécilia concert annuel que
l'industrie organise la guilde ouais ils
récoltent pas des studios québécois
cedex travail si le rhume 675 à peu près
studio québécois qui sont regroupés
ensemble c'est la plus grosse
association au bond en jeu vidéo
grosse d'europe qui utilisaient la plus
grosse coop mais en fait c'est une
coopérative ainsi sa matière encore plus
et le guil mais c'est la plus grande
association de ce type de jeux vidéo
puis chaque année on organise le 10 et
musical du jeu vidéo c'est un spectacle
symphonique sur des musiques de jeux
vidéo
on sait québécoise et internationale
cette année ça va être le 17 novembre
salle pierre mercure donc ceux qui nous
écoutent qui aiment la musique de jeu
vidéo puis le concert classique il faut
justement on parlait avant avant de
commencer par quatre en or stéphane et
hervé 6 puis elle a le comité a animé
une soirée à louer ce qu avec que ce ne
soit régie vidéo tmz c'est l'fun parce
que ça ramène toutes sortes de monde ça
ramène justement les habitués des salles
de concerts de musique classique qui
sont abonnées mettons pas le montcalm
qui ont ce spectacle les fans de jeux
vidéo les gamer pile il est curieux puis
sur demande placée comme ses meetings
potelets dans une même salle la musique
classique qualité
les vieux aussi au théâtre saint denis
l'an passé c'est vraiment méchant vos
spectacles puis cette année ça va être
encore meilleur à chaque année on
améliore la suite des pièces et tous les
choix des pièces et une trame narrative
là dedans aussi
ça c'est de la belle musique c'est bien
composer et puis ça en fait ouais ça
fait vraiment musique romantique le
soudan connaît aussi des petites sommes
un peu plus le jeu viodé fois des jeux
vidéo à l'origine c'est ya aussi le
spectacle plutôt ménage tout 8 bits ou
un jouet et des petits est tous un peu
plus me dis ouais il est des artistes
ration complète quand même comme dans la
variété de jeux qui existent
moi je joue beaucoup au final fantasy
qui fait la fantaisie la parenthèse ici
ce qui est que ça fait super longtemps
c'était je me suis appuyé sur quelle
console mais c'est vraiment le daily
graphic ce parlementaire habiter la
musique c'était comme
il y avait un nombre limité de faux
actes pouvait avoir en même temps la
musique d'instants leurs factures ce
test est vraiment rythme en terme et qui
défend la fantaisie c'est depuis le
début c'est le même compositeur qui
composent chaque au début c'est de la
musique 8 bit le super u de mentor à de
la musique orchestrale qui évolue et qui
fait tout ce qui dans d'enfin disent ici
sur une scène d'opéra puis mais c'est
vraiment super omaha 8 bits
pas grand chose
ils l'ont réarrangé l'on adapté pour ce
très beau concert pour orchestre avec
chanteuse de période puis c'est comme à
qui la petite musique et j'ai entendu le
sang va prendre une ampleur des
proportions fiscal parce qu'un quart de
plusieurs avec c'est sûr que oui comment
comment s'appelle la violoniste angèle
dubeau album les chansons et jeux vidéo
ce qui est fou c'est comme international
c'est très québécois comme idée
originale de faire un album qui sort un
peu des sentiers battus je pense pour ma
part amassé la musique était pas belle
plume dictée pas bonne le ferais peut
activer vraiment sûrement été lus n'est
ce pas compositeur puis justement ça
attire un public ou sic de curieux de
gens qui arrêtent pas nécessairement a
été vers la musique classique ç a épaté
d'assumer les voitures ne pas d'entrer
au site des photos qui aime ses beautés
musique l'homme a précicé courréjean la
gloire des cours et des gosses qui
découvre que andré mathieu lui
les spécialistes disent qu'à chaque
étape de sa vie était plus avancée que
mozart mathieu c'était vraiment un g10
incroyable de musique c'est sa cage de
sa vie étaient plusieurs à cyclomoteur
qui est vu comme le génie précoce
article il faut je pense qu'il est
puissant clergé avait mais il était
jeune jeunes ados 11 12 api était
dépression parce que ce pas lui qui
jouait sa composition dans un concert
cette fois des couches pourquoi donc est
vrai cerveau qui était un peu plus avoir
sectionné oui mais la mise en est que
pour les grands on apparaître en touche
mais s'est passé avant le but podcasts
ou après mais qu'est la musique
chez les jeunes développent le cerveau
d'une façon que vraiment puissante une
impression puis c'est moi j'ai folle
amis musiciens qui ont dit qu'ils ont
des enfants au sipi il s'est enfin le
hull kr exposé à la musique c'est tout
et surdoué
s'il ya vraiment quelque chose là dedans
qui est un que je suis sur youtube et sa
part éric billard au fait des vidéos de
théorie musicale surtout puis lui son
fils il n'aurait absolument développer
un point est ridicule portée et
promettre que je souhaite porter mais t
il fait des tests puis son enfant lafon
lui ce que fait pitié
certains diront que c'est excessif là
mais lui ce qu'il a fait c'est du moment
que sa femme est enceinte qui a été une
coupe de bois enceinte
il expose m et on y mettait de la
musique qui lui sait j'ai fait ça aussi
dix hectares sur l'abattant et puis
c'est exactement lui disais je mettais
de la musique il ya passé de la musique
à autun formation fait que ce soit toi
du jazz avec tes beaucoup beaucoup de
notes que l'information ou de la musique
ou du bac mais justement de la musique
la musique la musique actuelle ou cité
accueille beaucoup de s'annonce aussi
parce qu'ils aient été la dissonance t
les accords confesse lui lui il se
demandait si tu exposes un enfance par
jeunes a beaucoup de s'annonce comme
ceux est ce que c'est vous ce n'est
normal pour lui est-ce que ça est-ce que
ce n'est pas normal pour lui pis pich je
l'impression qu'il la réponse est un peu
oui parce que son fils qui lui joue
aujourd'hui les yeux comme dix ans puis
jules type rsa il s'assoit sur le piano
le tiff est comme n'importe quoi puis
son fils chanter doré n'est pas du tout
les noms des notes qui en tant pis il
entend tout c'est vraiment super
impressionnant
puis en plus de ça les petits gars t'es
les petits guèye
c'est ça vraiment surdoué mais ti y
apprend les langues comme ceux hills
états de multiplication it peut y faire
122 x 35 puis votre caisse a fait ces
tapis chasser le bourg toile
c'est pour tout le monde quoiqu'il quoi
de l'or de la mémoire là dedans aussi
j'ai l'impression puis je pense que leur
est absolue c'est de pouvoir reconnaître
n'importe quelle note si tu l'entends
est encore trop creux kulik mis ses
pistes à temps la corde la porte pas
grincé mais j'ai l'impression que ça
doit être faite de fatigue en pis mais
j'ai l'impression que si quelque chose
de l'ordre de la mémoire justement que
que timo je me souviens peau c'est quoi
un don vite comme souci sauf qu'il ya
des gens qui sont capables de s'en
souvenir progressant de leurs vite parce
que et puis je pense que c'est vraiment
à la petite enfance que qu'elle se
développe ce à l'exposition à la musique
qui as environnement lot probable car
c'est là tout le temps ouais je rêvais
savoir est universel il ya des jours où
je les ai toujours où j'arrivais un
petit peu à côté mais je rêve c'est de
l'avoir pile parce que j'ai l'époque
j'étais paul exact je sais ce qui se
sait apparemment quelque chose qu'à
l'âge adulte pu vraiment développé je
pense que oui mais la voir comme don
inné mais seppi façon tous les musiciens
mondiaux avoir l'oreille absolue c'est
pas nécessairement bonne finalité je
sais pas davantage mais tu peux très
bien tu peux avoir une très relative
absolument incroyable
si tu donnes quelqu'un avec une super
bonne relatifs à lui donner une note
d'après celui plus de trouver n'importe
quoi ces baisses c'est une dérange à
faire que ce kit est donné à la
naissance qui peut être donné à la
naissance le sang c'est inné moi parce
que c'est maintenant le petit gueule je
parle roulement que tu as raison il doit
avoir beaucoup de lien avec l'exposition
à la musique dans un beau âge mais il me
semble malgré tout avoir frappé un bon
numéro le dire je pense qu il
il ya les deux qui rentrent en ligne de
compte mais j'ai puis je pense que les
études là dessus au cpie de ce que
j'observe autour de moi l'exposition à
la musique en bas âge tu es vraiment
intenses répétées se dit qu'il ya
quelque chose qui se pressent déjà
complète la musique qui font juste
france et matt qui pourront pas de
musique qui il manque quelque chose
ça complète l'éducation les arts la
culture la musique je pense être est
obligatoire de façon plus intensive que
celui actuellement des cours de flûte à
bec
mais oui mais si j'aurais poussé ses
traits trivial c'est rudimentaire et
puis les a beaucoup qui est intensif
ça peut définitivement à être plus
mettre définitivement le président faire
là dessus d'ailleurs l'autre jour j'ai
ma blonde et chanteuses qui ont fait
beaucoup de musique ensemble puis on a
joué la semaine soit restée un battle de
band d'écoles primaires c'est comme le
meilleur ben de chaque école primaire
qui rencontre oui ça c'est vraiment ce
séance pas plus que la finale s'est
classé comme dix écoles qui
s'affrontaient chacun de toune d'automne
de rock le type il ya un gros ben avec
brasse avec drôme basse percussions tout
les kits plusieurs chanteurs c'était
vraiment au tribal primaire mais c'est
juste des capable de jouer dans le
rythme dû jouer ensemble à l'été ou
prima moi je pense pas que j'aurais pu
faire site
on a fait un show autres en secondaire 5
au show de fin d'année piti génétique un
temps de jeu de go puis je serai
n'étaient que 38 majeur de la batterie
ouais mais bref liquide les niveaux que
ces jeunes mais avez vous pris mars est
complètement c'est pour sgs était
probalement égale à deux niveaux qui
étaient des comédies on m'avait désirée
clary d'abc bah ouais ça je pensais
beaucoup plus de toxines qui a joué de
la batterie pour moi ce qui me concerne
ouais
six voitures ces jeunes là vivent un
moment qui même s'ils font pas de
musique d'alerté pour le restant de leur
vie ils auraient mal à rester quelque
chose de bon accord c'est encore jeune
j'ai ouais quand même
j'ai pété le sympathique ce qu'il est
actif
ceux qui restent intellectuellement
actif c'est souvent sur ce qui reste
encore est-ce que tu dors bien dors bien
mais peu à peu
ouais quand je me couche moi j'étais en
commun de roche le rhin j'ai vu dès
samedi mais je veux pas me coucher sur
mon problème tout le temps envie de
faire quelque chose d'autre que les
couches et pas parce que j'aime pas le
savez j'adore dormait mais au nom si tu
devais faire moyenne des commandes en
partie commence pas maintenant c'est un
peu plus le jeu de dormir
bon si ce n'est qu'il est un cachet plus
jeune c'était 3 400 vingtaine je dormais
en 4-5-1 n'était pas fatigué mais le
avec large ou d'énergie et un peu moins
grand donc après une nuit blanche allait
pas que ça me dérangeait pas le nuit
blanche la crème et nuit blanche c'est
rohff
je suis détruit j'ai peu dormi ou quoi
qu'est ce qu'il ya non mais c'est parce
que j'étais arrivé hier la veine général
de mamma mia je trouve et ce partant
chez nous après ce qu'en fera pas car
c'est aujourd'hui que tu es qui qu'on
n'avait pas tout pour finir de le monter
suffisait de monter le projet l'export
s'apprend comme drake sportif que je me
suis couché pendant deux heures je mon
cadran du temps je me suis réveillé la
bresse vosges l'envoya ph des clubs
s'apprêtent à renvoyer avec le je me
suis réveillé je l'envoyais en fait même
pas je me sens tron qui avait eu une
erreur dans le truck vacances que je
passe la nuit à me coucher me réveiller
ce contexte et à deux heures de la nuit
non mais je fais passer trop souvent
c'est là c'est la longévité qui goûte
j'essaie de dormir moins huit heures
puis j'écoutais un podcast autour son
sommeil puis tu sais que tu es comme 95
% du gisement ont besoin de leurs huit
heures c'est super important pour
régénérer ton service policier qu'on
apprend exactement
moi justement avec la musique si je m'en
a tellement conclu citant norman
j'apprends à mes enfants
genève les affaires 15 minutes avant de
me coucher maintenant je détourne à
prendre était calme et lent à me coucher
je me couche
l'homme est blessé puis inversement si
j'avais checker 2 jours 12 heures le
jour même puis qui a fallu que je les
joue le soir j'aurais été moins bons
qu'ils 15,9 et et parce que je le fais
comme si le fait de dormir ça s'aggrave
sur le sudiste moi je dis que je dois à
8h me sens mieux mais oui celle ci par
des lunettes pour je pense que
spécialise le tonique que j'écoutais dit
tu y ait des gens qui disent qu'ils
n'ont pas besoin beaucoup dormir qui
donnent trop t il j'en rigole charles
georges en trois heures par nuit
j'entends par là mon coup de barre
jusqu'à l'excès il dit y travaille on
veut pas le père me disait y dit il ya
certaines personnes qui ont un gène qui
fait qu'ils ont moins besoin de dormir
ces personnes-là ses six sorties mais
ils ont sinon le une bonne nuit 7h30 et
8h même n'avons arrêté pour tout le
monde
c'est au petit matin ouais parce que le
salut est trop fin ça fait longtemps
séparées avec des enfances sûrement bien
c'est ça le carillon entre 6 et 7 6
thématiques sont debout même s'ils sont
couchés par guy rien que je peux faire
pour rester couchés la pêche vont avoir
un bon délai légal
l'apport de l'extérieur tout individu
d'une chatterie oui c'est quelque chose
tu es bon défi quand même chaud je pense
que ça va s'améliorer que tapas qui
commence et autonome qui jouent ensemble
et tout ça donc c'est une chance d'avoir
quelqu'un du même âge la même étape et
tout ça mais au début pour les parents
c'est l'enfer les six premières années
je dormis un petit tout ça coïncidait
aussi avec fonder un nouveau parti
ça c'était la grande erreur mais c'est
très sain et éthique et sk rétrospective
m
est-ce que tu ferais la même chose mais
en fait tu peux pas dire que je voudrais
pas faire ce que je fais parce que les
gens que j'ai rencontrés
c'est dû à sa compta de connaître tous
n'optent dans une famille mais je
recommande à personne d'aller en
politique avec des jeunes enfants ou
d'avoir des enfants pendant qu'ils sont
apolitiques moi ça m'est arrivé quand je
me suis présenté à 2008 je veux pas
d'enfant et j'ai rencontré ma blonde
après puis ont eu deux enfants se
faisaient deux ans j'étais en politique
à peu près il la fondation des sourds
nationale est arrivé en 2000 ans après
2011 donc il y avait à peu près trois
ans un à part dont ils sont en 2010 et
que leur jeunesse ne manquez pas les
premiers bouts c'est pas le genre
d'affaires que tu peux reprendre et
peindre c'est ça le fait que les deux
premières années de leur vie j'étais pas
mal d'absences fait que c'est pour ça
que j'ai partie de l'option nationale
passait à l'aide plutôt bien le parti
quelque chose avec une bonne croissance
et même mouvement qui se faisait le même
si je n'ai pas gardé mon siège avec la
bannière l'option nationale en 2012 le
parti avait des membres qui rendaient en
masse puisque des membres jeunes
cet anniversaire step au club notamment
comment on dit tantôt c'était en même
temps que tous les mouvements étudiants
puis il y avait vraiment quelque chose
qui se passe et puis dans les
universités chez les jeunes athlètes
étaient très peu plus comme professeur
will et moi seul c'était mon prof de
philo ou peut-être même des fois en fait
c'est ça le même principe est
extrêmement gêne puis le discours était
rafraîchissant puis se passer quelque
chose puis malheureusement j'étais la
figure la plus connue
moi ce que je t'ai le sait le député
donc quand j'ai quitté s'est un peu
ralenti le progrès parti mais j'aimerais
savoir ce qui se serait passé si ça
l'était resté puis 90 monde mais était
resté dans le même parti
je serais curieux de voir aujourd'hui
mais je pouvais pas rester parce que je
ratais tout devient aussi mozart puis
juste pour moi
ça fait son temps exact que je
recommande à personne d'avoir des jeunes
enfants politique où est allé quand les
enfants sont encore très jeune s'est
passé quoi large optimale bruit à lille
que les enfants comprennent pas ce qui
manque pas de papa ou maman
mais même si on fait des aménagements à
l'assemblée nationale pour favoriser la
conciliation famille travail parce que
c'est le genre de boulot qui sait
concilier avec une famille jeunes c'est
trop prenant de tout le temps dans ta
tête tout le temps été suivi par tout le
temps au lendemain un politicien dit
quelque chose tu passes de suite à
comment réagir photo tact accepte
l'invitation de quelqu'un ou d'un groupe
à les voir parce que tu veux laisser le
temps que tout le temps en validant pas
ce métier là en fait donc la politique
moi je pense qu'il faut faire ça avant
ou après les enfermer pendant ce moment
mais c'est ceux qui équipent la dans ce
sens et qu'il soulage tama
les politiciens c'est des gens plus à
plus loin dans leur carrière tu des gens
des 40 50 60 qui fait que les jeunes se
sentent plus déconnectés fac c'est le
fun d'avoir des jeunes justement qui qui
qui viennent en politique par kiki qui
ont un nouveau discours qu'un nouvel
abaissement
certains ont déjà des enfants donc il
doit retrouver cette offre mais sont les
jeunes qui veulent y aller avant d'avoir
une famille c'est parfait parce que
c'était si quelqu'un qui est élu
catherine fournil fallu à 24 ans la plus
jeune de l'histoire donc avec lui à
20,87 encore la plus jeune du parlement
c'est son deuxième mandat un corps a été
livrée manger donc directement devant
des enfants après ces quatre phases de
politique et une couple d'années qui a
fait quelque chose après sa bonne
famille puis après ça ils reviennent si
elle veut mais d'avoir les affaires
pendantes et apolitique c'est sûr que tu
sacrifier du temps avec eux c'est sûr
c'est sûr que tu imposes ton conjoint ou
sa conjointe est monoparentale puis
d'avoir une vie un peu de foot pour moi
une expérience pas que ce soit ça la
politique avec des avants jaune puis à
l'oeil et de tenter un retour
une patiente est ce que c'est qu'encore
quelque chose que tu envisages
prochainement ou le saison pour un stage
va être sélective absolument pas la
politique m'intéresse toujours moi je
suis sûr puisque la moyenne des ours
mais un jour c'est quelque chose pour la
souveraineté contribuer comme je le peux
mais je pense que des moyens de faire
avancer des causes autres que des telus
en est un fantastique teste encore
d'accès se décide ça commence par les
mac les choses se décident de société
donc c'est l'instrument ultime je dirais
pour changer les choses mais il ya moyen
de faire plein de choses par la culture
par le développement économique
si c'est exact il n'était pas dans ton
nouveau mandat avec la guilde s'est pas
complètement pour relier je peux combler
le public
on dit que le jeu vidéo peut mener au
développement tels quelque chose depuis
d'implication sociale ou de d'impact
social ça c'est très bien aussi
puis je travaille aussi sur un projet
culturel à ce moment sur le québec
donc lieu à suivre sans plus de détails
mais ça c'est un projet qui peut faire
aussi connaître plein d'arguments puis
éveiller des gens des dossiers qui sont
pas habitués de suivre ses terres sans
être partie
parce que la politique partisane ça
marche plus ça dure rarement marché
c'était plus relié au fait que les gens
aiment et rené lévesque ou aimé robert
bourassa la partisanerie sa ferme des
oreilles puisque c'est un autre élément
j'ai envie de parler du québec sans
aucune partisanerie mais parler des
forces du québec une formule qu'on
entend souvent les gens veulent qu'on a
les moyens de nos ambitions
moi je veux qu'on ait les ambitions de
nos moyens parce qu'on a des moyens
infinis ici pour montrer qu'on ne
réalise pas qu'on est capable de faire
tout ce qu'on veut donc je me retrouve
l'ambition de nos moyens
je pense que par la culture ça peut se
faire soit par un spectacle d'être de
faire des projets à titre informatif qui
sont pas partisans souvent quand on
essaie d'être objectifs par rapport à
des sujets et qui y par l'information
comment je pense est faux ce record avec
les avec le début du podcast par
l'information sur halal sans dire la
vérité mais le chemin à suivre sur j ah
bah oui le fait de les gens tout le
monde est occupé tout le monde est pogné
avec la famille le travail tout ça puis
y'a pas le temps de s'intéresser à des
choses qui pourtant les touchent de très
près eksi et des podcasts par action
dans l'auto qui peut viser d'affaires ca
ou ou un spectacle ou un film ou une
série netflix n'importe quoi je pense
qu'encore une fois on revient la culture
qui peut changer les choses
les artistes plus vite que d'autres
d'autre part de sociétés il faut joindre
les gens là où ils sont quand ils sont
disponibles puis ils sont de moins en
moins et que ça aussi c'était devenu
compliqué de rejoindre les gens pour
faire avancer une cause parce qu'ils ont
peu de temps d'écouté où ils ont pu
envie d'écouter à cause des dernières
années en politique était moins belle
c'est jeudi soit là d'accord c'est quoi
le la solution pour ramener l'intérêt ça
va prendre quelques années avec des gens
qui les inspire cette subite et le
gouvernement actuel va peut-être
respirer bain du monde à s'y intéresser
ça n'est pas de circonstance mais je
pense que on a eu des années - bell au
québec la politique avec toutes les
allégations de corruption de
malversation que désintéressé beaucoup
de sens a écoeuré bain du monde je pense
que si au cours des prochaines années ou
du prochain mandat la politique
redevient ce que ça devrait être c'est à
dire la chose très noble qui vise
l'intérêt collectif
c'est la politique passe les gens
naturellement vont s'y intéresser parce
que votre génération en génération est
très ouverte aux choses dont l'impact
social et prix positif environnementale
etc et vous arrivez vous à votre âge
devant un portrait qui est déjà un peu
gâchée dans votre service qu'il faut pas
faire
ouais et que ça allait plus vieux comme
moi puis même les gens à 60 et 70 ans
ont grandi dans un modèle qu'ils ont
quand même bien servi donc c'est pas un
qui vont changer ce modèle en option une
bonne volonté le ça va venir d'une
génération qui voit le portrait d'entrée
de jeu qui est pas correct qui va
changer chose donc je pense que par le
changement naturel des élus des
décideurs des pdg et des décideurs
partout et des 6 2
ça va se faire naturellement ça peut
être un peu plus de temps que je suis
vraiment curieux de voir à quoi va
ressembler cette société lève ce
gouvernement le cac et la majorité des
élus
il y en ait deux justement qu'en parler
catherine fournier puis il ya d'autres
plus jeunes catherine fanni je pense qu
elle exactement notre âge 25 ans c'est
sûr mais quand que la majorité des élus
quatre générations vont être vraiment la
génération au pouvoir
je suis vraiment curieux puis excité de
voir ça va ressembler à quoi
moi je pense que sur les veaux réflexe
environnementalistes et assez collectif
malgré tout beaucoup qui disent
génération et nombriliste moi je trouve
que vous avez un esprit collectif très
développé de la guilde en est une preuve
louis entreprenante jeux vidéo sont bien
ensemble dans une courbe plutôt que d'y
jouer à manger l'autre pour être plus
gros points on aurait peut-être
pollution et 15 m donc je pense que vous
êtes plus collectif plus
environnementalistes très ouvert sur le
monde c'est très positif
il y en a qui dit on pas que ce soit une
génération d'enfants rois qui va qui va
être pas mal différente des autres qui
suivent je pourrais pas dit je peux
sociales acquises au début mais je me
casse
si on est vraiment des enfants rois je
sais pas si c'est une vraie critique ou
delta laissé par à coups de pierres nos
coups de pied au cul je sais pas si ils
vont vraiment être en fait c'est de la
poésie
ah ouais c'est ici
on n'est pas fait mais il faut faire
attention ce qu'ils veulent je veille à
un parent qui sait ce que nos parents
c'est ça que nos parents ont plus de
moyens que leurs parents parce que dans
mon cas c'est comme toute façon mais moi
j'ai quasiment j'écris souvent
l'impression que ça m'a appris que
finalement le matériel soit l'essentiel
sa génération
vous êtes un peu dans lego que les
applications touchant le serbe a depuis
n'importe quelle génération serait tombé
dans le même piège
c'est conçu pour être sauf que tu disais
juste avant je disais que je sais que ma
génération moi avons grandi dans un
milieu aisé avoir eu pas mal tout ce que
j'avais besoin de trop mais mes besoins
puis me désole
que finalement je l'essentiel c'est pas
nécessairement matériel les ego sont
mieux servis maintenant donc votre
génération est un la plus techno vous
avez là des égocentriques
sauf que sur le matériel génération si
celles qui veulent moins de voitures
mois le moins avoir une maison dont vous
êtes moins attachés à ces choses là puis
ça ça fait partie de la solution aussi
merci tout le monde vu deux chars qui ne
porte de garage un chalet en plus en
estrie où on des laurentides
ça c'est vraiment de la surconsommation
qui peut pas se faire à large échelle je
pense que là dessus vous avez une bonne
solution c'est moins matérialiste est ce
que est ce que ça passe aussi par des
personnalités fortes
je pense que toujours toujours ça
s'apprend et ça prend des leaders ça
prend des leaders
j'aimerais des modèles inspirés ton
envie de suivre puis la politique ça
devrait pas être juste une personne ça
doit être des idées puis on les aime que
le porteur les monos il faut pas
d'imposer une cause parce qu'on aime pas
le chef est l inverse pourquoi et
médicaux juste parce qu'on aime le chef
de la cause est tout croche
ouais mais il ya demeure pas moins que
dans nature humaine va devoir quelqu'un
qui nous inspire et puis qu'on aime puis
qu'on a envie de suivre ça fait
accélérer les choses incroyablement rené
lévesque ce méchant bon exemple je tue
tous les micros début le début on
recommence depuis des mois faute
d'armand donc d'avoir le ou la bonne
leader à la bonne place pour la bonne
cause le ccc le package parfait parce
que des gens sont encore attachés et
c'est lui qui voit ses roues à personne
je passe les personnalités sont très
très importants
il pense tu prends une grosse question
mais penses tu pouvoir être cette
personne
non non à ce point je sais pas s'il faut
miser non plus sur cette personne là si
elle existe ou qu'elle soit dans une
équipe moi j'admire des gens politique
que d'autres attirent pas et vice versa
et déjà que pierre karl péladeau a tiré
que moi je tire pas signé jacques
alexandre cloutier attiré que je dire
pas et vice versa donc il faut que tous
ceux qui ont la même idée dans ce que si
c'est la souveraineté mais ça peut être
l'environnement ça peut être l'éducation
pour tous ceux que la même idée se
mettent ensemble qui étaient chacun leur
ce fragment de la population pilot ils
vont être majoritaire quand on tombe
dans l'eau c'est lui le meilleur chef
pour lui et lui qui gagne pas s'en va
chez eux
second gros jamais de même il faut que
les gens acceptent de mettre les ego de
côté
et tous travaillent ensemble pour une
cause puis à ce moment celle qui est le
plus en vogue c'est peut-être
l'environnement il faut que tout ce qui
se voit comme le chef des
environnementalistes travail avec
l'autre qui se voit comme le chef de
l'environnement tel un peu comme la
guideront les projets là qu'il est un
excellent exemple de seuils et plein de
petits entrepreneurs qui sont convaincus
d'avoir la meilleure idée du jeu mais
travaille quand même ensemble puis mais
me spread du staff dans les périodes de
pluies plus intenses et c'est formidable
collaboration qu'il est alors que par
exemple dans le modèle économique
fondamentale votre part du gâteau ils
prêteraient jamais un employé qui est un
peu plus de temps au studio rival qui
peut peut-être faire un jeu plus vite
que lui mais dans ce cas ci la guilde
dix prêtres du monde
puis tout le monde va plus vite c'est
vraiment phénoménal l'esprit de
collaboration qui dans cette entreprise
c'est un modèle à réfléchir pour une
plus grande échelle
en fait au québec comme c'est tantôt on
est on est sans doute parmi six noms les
plus avancés dans le monde la tue c'est
le chiffre d'affaires de l'économie
sociale ce que j'appelle l'économie
sociale de ces de l'entrepreneuriat
collectif c'est tout un peuple les obnl
mais qui sont en business c'est pas du
communautaire c'est vraiment des
entreprises qui doivent avoir des
revenus pour être rentable et survivent
donc les clubs les obnl ses 48 milliards
un chiffre d'affaires du québec
ça c'est 3 à 4 fois l'aéronautique qui
l'homme d'autres gros secteur de
l'économie sociale c'est trois quatre
fois plus grand que l'aéronautique donc
le québec là tu est extrêmement
développé puis c'est ça qui fait en
sorte que l'une des sociétés les plus
égalitaires au monde les plus équitables
le taux de criminalité est parmi les
plus bas au monde ici on a vraiment une
bénédiction et au québec en 2009
définitivement souvent que les livres
ont fait qu'est-ce que je colle si si
quand tu commences à poser les vraies
questions le questionne le site du un
petit j'ai souvent sacrée cote il va
mais je pense que pour des enfants à
gratter dans un environnement où il ya
quatre saisons avec du chaud du froid
c'est aussi ça développe le cerveau -
formidable content qu'on ait fait ça
c'est le temps de la plus haute mais mes
souvenirs les plus frappants s'est joué
dans le jeu penchait plus de souvenirs
d'un univers que je trouve agréable
c'est sûr c'est plus long aussi d'un
pilote je pense qu'ils en bavent de plus
en plus bizarre
les changements climatiques les
bouleversements mais d'abord quatre
saisons je trouve qu'une force ça coûte
cher aux magiciens on n'avait pas des
millions à mettre chaque année en
déneigement concours et matérielles
j'étais consommation électrique
ça marque les temps dans l'imaginaire ou
city on voit les années passées on voit
tc com
c'est comme la dnat vie marquée aux
normes divers qu'on a passé en 2006 que
j'aimerais trop bas je l'écouté mais
tout le monde me trouve chanceux de ne
pas avoir commencé la classe g plaisir
la bonne nouvelle
la bonne nouvelle c'est que vous avez
pas été déçu la boit pas la fin ac c'est
une catastrophe
à ce point là une catastrophe à tous les
points de vue mais en fait je sais pas
si on veut vraiment marquer entre
parenthèses game of thrones de mais je
pense que dd des studios comme comme et
du bio puis ça j'imagine qu'on peut
prêter le modèle à plusieurs autres
studios qui doivent leur succès ben qui
doivent en fait leur existence au public
aux spectateurs à ceux qui consomment ce
j'ai l'impression que souvent la pensée
bascule vers le vous êtes vous écouter à
cause que nous on existe et non on
existe parce que vous écoutez py.g la
maison l'exception de deux mois j'ai
l'impression que ce qui s'est passé
c'est qu'ils ont pas du tout considéré
le fait qu'il y avait du monde qui était
réellement investis dans cette série le
et en fait on va fermer la boucle parce
que notre argent et fait pas ce qu'on
veut passer à une autre série qui va
encore nous faire nous procurer de
l'argent sans aucune considération pour
ceux qui ont mis énormément de temps
dans ceux qui sont investis réellement
qui ont été finalement à cause de leur
succès le dc avait pas de public qui ont
été des matchs on dirait une saison avec
terminé sauf que là tout ce public là
qui étaient vraiment intéressés qui ont
juste pris la finale qui aurait dû être
fait sur vraiment plus longtemps et
l'ont mis dans une petite boule plonge
bien poubelle avec aucune considération
pour ceux qui avaient mis huit ans à
suivre cette série là à 8 ans et l'ont
laissé leurs huit ans c'est long de
votre vie
ça fait longtemps activement j'ai hâte à
la prochaine saison plusieurs autos
prochain épisode puisque qu'il a tout ce
monde là que ça fait huit ans qu'ils
sont intéressés par saab a aucune
considération pour eux si je trouve que
c'est pitoyable
oui peut-être quelqu'un quelque part qui
pensaient que c'est une bonne idée de
finale ou si j'en doute vraiment parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de vidéos sur internet
qui circulent
pardon pour ce qui est des membres et du
cast des acteurs et du des producteurs
qui parle de la série avant même
qu'elles sortent en disant genre finale
l'acteur principal qui fait john snow et
les genres dépression il vaut vraiment
pas billy lenteur principal y ait eu il
y avait une entrevue s'est fait demander
travers le personnage si ce personnage
principal il s'est fait demander avant
la série avec la série sorte une fois
que c'est fini de tourner ce fait dire
si tu avais un mot pour décrire la série
las la finale je suis dirait
automatiquement
il ya 10 de ce point thing prix offert
est spectaculaire c'était trop tard
mettez ton premier mot ça a été seul
c'est mauvais politicien son prochain
contrat
ayadi spectacle pitt et ça en dit long
le carton acteur principal
premier mot qui vient c'est de se
pointer puis je dire c'est juste parce
que je trouve que c'est un peu un manque
de respect pour les personnes qui sont
la raison pour laquelle tu existes au
final le public c'est le fun de le
considérer qu'après ouidah oui c'est
exact ips et c'est tout les domaines
soit pareil c'est le domaine du jeu
vidéo c'est le même principe l'été pour
reprendre assassin's creed et ils
peuvent pas sortir un avis maintenant
peuvent pas faire un jeu ça ceux ouverts
depuis le dernier qui ont sorti l'ex
passe dans la dans la grèce la grèce
antique
c'est un match de pc le meilleur de la
série lycée puis le monde maintenant
s'ils sortaient d'un prochain vraiment
garrocher c'est juste un manque de
respect pour les gens qui vont l'acheter
qui me quittent les gens qui sont la
raison pour laquelle tu encore le droit
d'en faire un autre encore les l'argent
en faire un autre pour donner de
l'emploi pour faire rouler ses fixe de
trancher puis il filme aussi qui en a
découlé je n'ai pas vu le film avec moi
non plus je l'évoqué moyenne masque de
montres pas ton public pour acquis c'est
comme tu abandonné l'envi décrite
quelque chose des grandes un peu le
phénomène mais tel qu ils vont acheter
les albums peu importe comment faire je
pense qu'ils se fassent leur corps mais
où est-ce qu'ils l'ont pris pour celles
qui ont encore des nouveaux albums
brochés avec autour d'un accord mais de
vos albums le dernier album était bon je
suis sam ayant eu une part de moi
c'était de la merde là pour pour un
groupe de musique c'est vraiment
difficile quand tu marques à l'époque de
la pression reste à la vente
est-ce que qu'est ce que tu fais ce que
tu te réinvente et essaie de rester
actuelle puis il suffit qu'ils perdent
les pires des fans qui étaient là depuis
le début qu'ils sont attachés à ce sont
le hubei continue dans la même affaire
mam année ça tu gagneras site s'est dit
prêt dans ma vie d'artiste que j'écoute
pas bien mais chez nous le puits ou
vraiment mon genre mais madonna depuis
le début de sa carrière a vraiment eu
des états se satisfait riels c'est un
exemple incroyable adaptés aux nouveaux
oui madonna d'artistes madonna en plus
ses dents dans le monde du pape ou est
ce que ça change rapidement pour passer
un ordre pitié les modes puis les traîne
ça change pas rapidement
quelle est sa une carrière qu'ils auront
aussi longtemps que justement tu
regardes pas d'être 80 90 ou 2000 à la
des gros hits qui ont marqué des
générations
c'est assez impressionnant il ya la peau
tant que t'y mets ton teyou tout en
prêtant bendahmane c'est maintenant
qu'ils ont été il y avait un son qui ont
tiré 21 époque picon qui ont su changer
survie complice à bord d'un tapis
l'époque je trouve que cette île 2 et
pack contenant différentes mais j'aime
autant de nouveaux matériels qu elle non
plus pas plus si ce n'est son opinion et
pas la raison
l'original complet je pense qu'ils
affament quelque chose d'avoir signé
comme pas de filtre de jugement webcam
et enfin une demi tonne
je la garde je le développe c'est bon
c'est bon
celle ci comme l'attestent mais ce n'est
pas le seul test dans mon goût la fille
se réveille un champ thalathoun que joue
à la veille de freedom ce que j'avais
composé la veille en se réveillant sagem
baisse ça veut dire que la mélodie mais
malade ça accroche un peu
par chance bien ok à les enfants faut
[ __ ] laisser partir why s l'aimé
vraiment merci pour l'invitation
ça faisait les os merci beaucoup à lui